[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm unix sieg bei
hertha ließ und seine theorie der
veränderung versprochen
heute werden wir sein werk über die
seele oft nach dem lateinischen titel
der anima genannt es kann sein dass ich
aus versehen ab und zu deren immer und
nicht über die seele sagen werde werde
mich aber nicht auch an der sozusagen
und wir werden diese woche und nächste
woche dieses werk beschränken dann
kommen zwei wochen so ethik beirat wir
sind dann die letzte sitzung wo die
klausur stattfinden wird und das besser
zu verstehen wollte ich sie daran
erinnern was sich letzte woche über
veränderung gesagt habe denn diese
theorie der veränderung eine wichtige
rolle in seine psychologie spielt
übrigens am das griechische wort für
seele ist super
und deswegen haben wir das wort
psychologie ja also man spricht manchmal
auch in der in der antike schiffmann von
psychologie aber im sinne von
philosophische theorie der seele und
nichts psychologie wie wir das heute
verstehen ok letzte woche haben wir
gesehen dass in einer typischen
veränderung oder in jeder anderen sogar
bremer drei prinzipien haben nämlich
eine materie die dorf die veränderung
konstant bleibt also bleibt erhalten
könnte man sagen und dann die
abwesenheit eines einer form also nichts
für die abwesenheit oder mangel dieser
form und dann gesprochen
zum beispiel sokratis wird musikalisch
oder holz wird tesch dieses beispiel mit
holz ist ganz intuitiv weil wir hier
wirklich holz als die materie des
tisches einordnen würden aber bei so
kritik bei dem beispiel mit socket kann
man sollte dies so sein mit metaphorisch
als die materie beschreiben also sorgt
hier spielt die rolle die holz bei dem
tisch beispiel spielt das heißt soccer
teams ist das was durch die veränderung
erhalten bleibt was sich verändert ist
dass er zuerst nicht musikalisch ist und
dann musikalisch
jetzt muss ich ein paar wörter einführen
die ich glaube ich letzte woche nicht
angehört habe nämlich prozent sanitäts
und aktualität oder wirklichkeit
im allgemeinen das nochmal ganz intuitiv
wir können sagen und das holz holz in
form von bretter oder einfach stücke von
holz die auf dem boden liegen sind noch
kein tesch sind aber potenziell ein
tisch das heißt dass der holz die
fähigkeit hat ein tisch zu werden
oder ich bin potenziell geigenspieler
vielleicht vielleicht bin ich jetzt zu
alt aber mach ich hier von ihnen sind
prozent jährigen spieler haben sie haben
noch die fähigkeit geige zu lernen oder
ich bin potenziell swahili sprechen
ich kann zwar kein israeli könnte aber
es war healey kenntnisse erwerben
ja wir sind alle potenziell es war hier
wobei hat kann jemand hier so hering
also er ist aktuell das weiche licht
brachte
dass diese frage haben sie
wahrscheinlich nicht erwartet heute
schon wieder ein professor wissen wer es
war hier richtig
also er ist aktuell nicht ich breche wir
alle nur prozent ja ein bisschen
kompliziert als dass wir sie sehen
werden aber das ist die und das ist die
eigentliche idee also können wir sagen
im allgemeinen dass die materie die
rolle der potenzial i tät spielt oder
wir können uns auch in dem die
potenziale hat seinen sitz in der
materie
das heißt holz ist potenziell ein tisch
kann die form des tisches erwerben
da sieht man man greift nach würde wie
cannes oder weg haid deswegen potenziell
oder sorgt dies ist prozent ist der
potentially tät nach musikalisch das
wort für potenzial i tät auf griechisch
ist dynamisch und man kann sagen zb
andrew name potenzial oder der
potenzielle täter nach also all dies hat
ein dynamisch musikalisch werden holz
hat du name ist es zu werden die form
ist ein aktualität oder wirklichkeit
er ist das griechische wort
normalerweise keine ag auch enthält her
das ist natürlich woher wir das wort
eine energie haben
gibt es deutsche worte die von dünnes
abgeleitet werden also auf dynamisch wer
ein beispiel
dynamo war das also kraft ist in dem
dynamo das ist irgendwas mit strom oder
dynamo gut ich bin weder strom kenner
noch so ähnlich becker weiß nicht warum
sie nicht erlauben diese verletzungen
überhaupt zu halten
da ist so und müssen ok natürlich ist
diese ist der mangel der form keine
wirklichkeit und normal mein mann könnte
irgendwie sagen der holz ist aktuell
oder in der wirklichkeit kein tisch aber
das ist dass es sehr komisch und
normalerweise verwendet das wort wie es
wirklichkeit oder aktualität nur einer
der nur mit der erworbenen
so wie sie sein werden wird diese idee
eine wichtige rolle oder diese ganz
analyse eine wichtige rolle hin dass
diese story der serie seiner psychologie
bevor ich das sehe komme hat jemand
fragen weil ich glaube ich habe keine
zeit für fragen
letzte woche gab hat jemand fragen zu
dieser theorie bevor ich dann weitergehe
eine solche klage über diese ich habe
letzte woche gesagt das ist bei europa
das wort wie es oft vorkommt dass er
irgendwie der erste ist der einen
traktor zu einem bestimmten thema
scheint zum beispiel ist er der erste
der ein traktat wovon wir ein erhaltenen
traktat zur literatur haben die politik
oder er ist nicht der einzige der der
erste der zur rhetorik geschrieben hat
dass eine ausnahme aber er ist der ist
der erste der physik nach unserem
verständnis der physik in unserem
verständnis unserem verständnis gewidmet
hat er ist der erste der ein booster
ethik geschrieben hat nico magische
hitzig und sogar ein weiteres werk so
hätten und so weiter und so fort
und das trifft auch hierzu das ist dass
er das erste buch der geschichte der
westlichen philosophie und
wahrscheinlich auch der geschichte der
fluss wie schlechthin weil ich weil
keine chinesische oder indische zarte
seele mehr anfallen die früher sind das
anders dort reserve könnte mich dahin
er ist der erste der ein werk über die
seele geschrieben hat allerdings ist ja
nicht der erste der zum thema überhaupt
dass ich zu diesen thema überhaupt
äußert vielmehr gibt es viele
ideen zu erzählen die schon in
vorherigen philosophen zu finden sind
und für ihn auch zu finden waren
und er will sie hernehmen etwas wie
stoff was er was er verwenden kann um
das thema zu definieren und vorzustellen
und damit er auch schon vielleicht nicht
die richtige theorie findet dass die
diese kritische theorie hat nur er
seiner meinung nach aber er kann so
seien erste schritte in die richtige
richtung finden
genau wie wir bei der physik gesehen
haben also sie rennen sich daran
daher gefragt wie viele prinzipien der
natur gibt dass da kritisierte alle
diese vorgänge nicht nur vor sondern hat
platon und dann kommt ja endlich zu
dieser analyse und diese dialektische
argumentationsweise die immer benutzt
das heißt er nimmt immer ideen oder
meinungen von anderen denkern und
benutzt sie und massiert sie so sagen
irgendwie damit die richtige theorie
herauswächst
das ist die ästhetische theorie oder die
aristotelische methode schlechthin
also erst dafür sehr bekannt dass er
immer das tut er eigentlich nicht immer
aber ziemlich oft in vor allem in den
wichtigsten werken fängt er mit einem
überblick der vorherigen philosophen an
und dann geht er weiter so seine eigene
theorie
das ist wie er arbeitet sozusagen
gesundheit und wir werden dann wenn wir
nächste woche ist eine technologie nähe
bestritten werden sie vielleicht sehen
warum er gute gründe hat zu denken dass
diese methode wirksam wäre also erst
kurz um ist er der meinung dass unsere
geister geschaffen sind so sollen also
nicht von einem schöpfer aber die sind
so gestaltet dass sie die welt begreifen
können also die welt ist begreiflich und
es ihre geister sind gut im begreifen
dass von der natur aus und von daher
wäre es irgendwie seltsam wenn alle die
wenn diese ganze schlaue leute alle
versucht hätten die serie zu definieren
und gar keine gute ideen hatten
das heißt nicht dass sie ihrem erreicht
haben natürlich normalerweise haben sie
nie ganz rechts also er muss immer
verbesserung dann einführen
aber die haben fast immer was zu sagen
und außerdem hat er eine ganze theorie
die dialektische argumentation und
funktioniert wo er ausdrücklich sagt
dass man von meinungen ausgehen soll
die von entweder von den meisten leuten
dann betreten sind oder von denen weisen
ob diese dialektische terre die wirklich
hier eingesetzt wird ist fraglich und
kontrovers aber irgendwie ist das
typisch westfälisch dass man von weit
verbreiteten meinungen anfängt oder von
meinungen die berühmten philosophen zu
finden sind
das wäre ein bisschen also ob wir zum
beispiel eine debatte über politik
führen würden und an sie würden
vielleicht nicht sagen
nein ich wohne mit frank und er sagt vom
punkt sie würden aber viel mehr sagen
marx sagt punkt von fonds und sie können
das einfüllen aus eine prämisse war ein
berühmter für das auf das gesagt hat
oder sie könnten sagen na ja alle würden
sagen
sklaverei ist falsch oder sowas also
dann rufen sie auf eine weit verbreitete
meinung
und diese prämisse ist legitim zu sagen
das muss ja alles hier machen
unter anderem weil die ähnlich wie
physik oder die natur in der physik ist
es relativ unklar
nach dass diese meinung was das thema
hier überhaupt ist also alle sprechen
ich habe in altgriechisch von der psyche
also von der seele
aber es ist ziemlich unklar was es heißt
von seele zu sprechen und als beispiel
dafür könnte ich einen text erwähnen was
ihnen vielleicht schon eingefahren ist
als mögliches gegenbeispiel zu dem was
ich gesagt habe nämlich dass das der
erste traktor seele ist hoffentlich
haben manche von ihnen gedacht was ist
aber mit platte und 23
da haben wir wochenlang darüber
gesprochen dass wir dort eine es allen
theorie haben wieso zählt das nicht und
ich würde sagen dass das nicht zählt
weil es keine allgemeine behandlung des
themas seele ist sondern eine behandlung
der frage ob die seele unsterblich ist
da geht es wirklich nur darum zu sagen
ob die serie mit dem körper stirbt oder
nichts das ist die das ist der zweck des
fonds er und nie in dem fall dann finden
wir eine passage wo solche teams das an
ein stück nimmt und sagt zuerst müssen
wir definieren was wir überhaupt unter
seele verstehen da gewinnt natürlich
sehr viel einsicht in platons allen
verständnis aus diesem dialog aber das
ist offenbar keine allgemeine
besprechung der seele
statt dessen was wir dass wir im
weiteren finden sind wichtige ideen über
die serie zum beispiel dass die zellen
nicht mit dem körper identisch ist
das nimmt ja fast an oder nimmt er sogar
an ausdrücklich oder das zähle ein
prinzip des lebens oder leben versagt
irgendwas mit leben zu tun hat
also man kann schon eine vielleicht eine
allgemeine theorie der seele aus dem
weiten entnehmen ist aber trotzdem
meiner meinung nach kein tag wo man den
man erstens ist ein dialog aber es
abgesehen davon das ist kein tat zur
seele in allgemeinen sinne das alles
hier internet also muss man also wenn
man in dieser situation ist wurde es
schließlich befindet muss man sich
fragen ob ich was versteht man grob und
seele
und dann sagt er was ganz interessantes
was uns vielleicht nicht sofort
einfallen würde er ist sagt seele ist
immer mit zwei anderen begriffen
verbunden
wenn man andere philosophen liest und
vielleicht einfach nach allgemeinem
sprachgebrauch nämlich wahrnehmung
und bewegung es interessant der seien
nicht leben
ein führt als grundlegendes prinzip oder
grundlegendes phänomen was wir erkennen
wollen
weil jemand mich fragen würde was ist
die seele oder was soll die serie
erzählen erklären ich würde
wahrscheinlich sagen dass dieses prinzip
des lebens ist nicht das prinzip der
wahrnehmung und bewegung aber natürlich
wenn man sagt seele vor sach leben
dann stellt man sofort die frage was was
verstehen wir aber unter leben also mein
meine vermutung wäre das alles irgendwie
leben unter diesen zwei begriffen zwar
unter einem hut bringen wird also das
was lebt ist das was wahrnehmen kann und
das was sich bewegen kann erinnerung
bewegung ist für das sollte diese
breiter als nur örtliche bewegung könnte
zb erwachsensein oder farbe für ein
fahrrad veränderung sein
und von daher fühlen sich schon sehen
dass die seele also wenn die seele das
ist was in die fähigkeit der wahrnehmung
oder interne bewegung dann bereit stellt
dann müssen wir anerkennen dass nicht
nur menschen würden nach noch mal wenn
ich sage seele
sie denken was zuerst und vielleicht
sogar nur an die menschliche seele aber
offensichtlich können allen die die
tiere wahrnehmen und sich bewegen
hunde können sehen sie können laufen und
sogar pflanzen nehmen was vielleicht
nicht war übrigens pflanzen nehmen schon
war
es ist wirklich interessant zum beispiel
haben sie bewiesen dass weiß also ich
kann das ist natürlich nichts aber sie
haben bewiesen dass pflanzen wenn sie
ihre wurzeln durch erde
dann schicken also sagen dass sie
manchmal hindernisse vorhersehen und in
eine andere richtung wachsen also so
oder so was
aber bevor sie mit dem stahl in kontakt
kommen wie sie das machen ist etwas
rätselhaft wie er immer gelesen pflanzen
pflanzen kriegen 1 1 von verbesserten
sich hier der kriegen 1 1 erwähnen war
pflanzen können sich aber sicherlich
bewegen weil sie wachsen können
sie können auch nahrung dann einnehmen
und verarbeiten das alles bewegung in
brighton sinne von daher ist es mehrere
varianten von der ersten seite klar dass
alles so wie es mit seiner
psychologischen theorie vielmehr
erklären will als das was alles was
platon besprochen hat in dem fall meine
ich denn erstens die das thema serie
allgemein beschweren will wie gesagt und
zweitens versucht ja hier nicht nur
menschliche seele zu sprechen sondern
alle zellen und zwar von menschen tieren
und pflanzen
vielleicht würden sie sich jetzt würden
sie jetzt befürchten dass alles bei uns
bezahlt wird was ich meine was bleibt
übrig was hat keine seele so was wie
erde also ein stein hat keine seele war
ein stein kein erstens nicht wahrnehmen
kann und zwar es keine bewegung
unternehmen kann selbst das ist nicht
ganz klar weil wenn ich ein stein bahn
lasse würde alles sagen dass der stein
fällt weil der stein an die natur hat
die nach dem mittelpunkt des universums
neid
man könnte sich fragen ob er nicht
irgendwie sagen sollte das setzt steine
besetzt sind
aber für ihn mindestens technologisch
das beseelte ist das was mindestens eine
pflanzliche seele hat nämlich die
fähigkeit sich zu ernähren zu wachsen
und so weiter also dass das bereich wo
wir wo
uns befinden und noch mal sie können
jetzt sehen dass es genau das bereich
was wir mit dem wort leben bezeichnen
also dass das was für uns lebt ist genau
das was für alles dort ließ eine seele
hat pflanzen tiere menschen gott und so
weiter kompliziert aber er konnte nicht
vor also wir machen uns keine sorgen
jetzt über gott noch nichts mindestens
also was haben andere philosophen zu
dieser frage gesagt
zuerst ist es sehr klar bei den anderen
philosophen dass sie eine grundlegende
unterscheidung machen genau die genau
die unterscheidung die wir bei platt
angefangen haben nämlich seele und
körper also die die unterscheiden alle
zb paar männer dies der gar keine
unterscheidungen haben will weil der
mann ist ist aldi sich zur seele äußern
unterscheiden zwischen seele und körper
ich habe aber als wir den fall
angeschoben haben sie darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass man zwischen seele und
körper unterscheiden kann ohne
katalanisch platonisch touristisch zu
denken also nur dass man wenn wir diese
unterscheidung sehen das erste was uns
einfällt es wahrscheinlich dass die
zelle nicht körperlich ist also eine mrt
reale nicht physikalische entität das
ist aber nicht zwingend der fall
man könnte sagen unterkörper verstehe
ich dass mein körper aber die seele ist
eine weit ist ein weiterer körper
vielleicht ein weiterer körper in meinem
körper
das wäre was also man sagen würde das
was mir wahrnehmung und bewegung
bereitstellt ist mein gehirn also meine
seele ist mein gehirn oder in maine
deren bedeutung sich manchmal
nationalistische völlig offen ist
heutzutage hast du sagen wenn wir eine
seele haben oder sie würden eher von
gleis oder mein sprechen
sie würden es sowas sagen wie gemein das
erste break
der geist ist nur gehirn das wäre als ob
man sagen würde ja ja ich bin bereit
anzuerkennen dass sie dass ich ein geist
oder seele habe aber das ist nur ein
teil meines körpers oder aspekt meines
körpers oder wie er immer eine weise
dachten manche vor so kritiker dass die
seele ein körperliches prinzip ist was
in dem groben festen körper befindet zum
beispiel herr doug reid verwendet seele
mit vorhersagt sehr schön dass man das
betrunkene leute sich so benehmen wie
sie sich benehmen weil ihre säle
gedämpft gedämpftes also ein bisschen
feucht geworden ist durch das alkohol
also das vorher ist die flamme city
interessiert vielleicht nicht sehr
beeindruckend als theorien aber also
irgendwas fällt ihnen schon diese leute
muss man zugeben kann man jeden haben's
in welchen innenstadt erleben
all diese feuchte leute die rumlaufen
dass ein beispiel aber vielleicht das
beste beispiel ist die theorie dass er
die diakonissen vorschlagen vorschlagen
haben nämlich werden so einen körper der
aus atomen besteht aber diese aber an
was man vielleicht nichts über anti atom
ismus weiß ist dass die antipathie
müssten normalerweise sie sich
vorgestellt haben dass es viele arten
und größen von atomen gibt vielleicht
sogar alle möglichen größen hat man
könnte vielleicht sogar vorstellen dass
es atomen gibt die so groß sind
die werden sehr gefährlich natürlich
weil man sie nicht widerstehen kann
und die finden wir in unserem universum
nicht aber vielleicht sind sie irgendwo
draußen also außerhalb unserer welt oder
die welt wo wir uns befinden
denn die atom aston dachten dass wir das
das ganze universum unendlich groß ist
und dass es unendlich viele atomen
vielleicht von unendlich viele gestalten
und größen sind aber hier haben haben
wir einheimische kommen die kleinsten zu
klein zu sehen zu kleins zu fassen und
so und es heißt dass viele arten und
also vielleicht haben sie hatten sind
sie quadrat vorne oder wie auch immer
daraus bestehen unsere körper die seele
besteht aus kleinen runden hut kommen
die sehr glatt sind ein bisschen wie
fancy pants dass er dieses spiel was man
in den 70er hatte
vielleicht heißt es anders auf deutsch
aber es gibt diese ist wo man so egal
ist ein global in dem spiel ist ein
kleiner runder ball als eisen und platz
und die idee ist weil sie glatt sind
können sie sich sehr schnell durch den
körper bewegen wie wasser vielleicht
oder oder quecksilber und es gibt eine
frage es gibt ein fragment von demokrit
der
eigentlich der begründer des atheismus
wo er die seele in den körper so
kraxelte in einer puppe vergleicht also
man kann sie sich vorstellen
wir haben eine ein eine puppe aus holz
wir tun quecksilber rein und quecksilber
kann sie haben wenn sie jemals einen
thermometer zerbrochen haben
sie haben gesehen wie der quecksilber so
über ihn läuft und wir diese kleine also
nimmt die form von kleinen bällchen
haben sie das gesehen ja die ältere
leute haben das gesehen
junge leute sie können ihre
hochgeschätzte vorfahren fragen wie was
quecksilber was war das jetzt haben sie
handys und glauben kann
vielleicht gibt es krieg so seien handys
es gibt wahrscheinlich alles mögliche
unter dem was schädlich ist auf jeden
fall
das hat demokrat auch beobachtet und er
schlägt vor man können sie sich
vorstellen dass die diese puppe sich
dann bewegen könnte wenn der quecksilber
ist ich weiter so hin und her rollen
würde ist eine sehr anschaulich und nett
und übrigens vielleicht nicht ganz
falsch weil es ein bisschen als ob er
auch sowas deutet wie ein nervensystem
in einem körper was natürlich auch ist
ein körperliches system innerhalb eines
größeren systems und das innere des
systems ist feiner und subtiler als der
körper insgesamt also die details hat er
ganz falsch aber irgendwie ist es nicht
so lächerlich was er gesagt hat okay
also hier haben wir sowas wie
körperliches dualismus wie ich auch
damals bei weiteren gesagt habe aber
alles offen ließ nachdem er das alles
erklärt dann sagen kann diese theorie
ist nicht sehr überzeugend weil sie
mehrere probleme hat erstens
es hat zwar gesagt dass die seele
bewegung erklären sollte die seele soll
aber auch erklären können warum wir uns
manchmal nicht bewegen
zum beispiel wenn wir schlafen und es
ist naturgemäß das wir schlafen
es gehört irgendwie so liegt die
lebensfunktionen dass wir jede nacht
ruhen müssen aber wenn die serie
wirklich ein prinzip ist was nur den
körper in bewegung bringt dann können
wir uns nicht vorstellen oder wir können
nicht erkennen wie die seele den körper
zum schlafen bringt das ist glaube ich
ein sehr guter einwand wenn er wirklich
wie quecksilber in europa ist müsste man
sagen dass der quecksilber irgendwann
zur ruhe kommt aber die ganze idee ist
dass sie aus diesen gründen atomen
besteht die sehr schnell überall hin
bewegen können
das ist ein problem ein weiteres problem
ist dass er sich nicht vorstellen kann
und das ist wirklich philosophisch sehr
sehr wichtig dieses problem haben wir
immer noch er sagt ich kann mir nichts
ich kann nicht verstehen wie diese
atomen denken sollten
dies sind nur atomen die sind nur körper
wie sollen sollten körper irgendwie
denken später wie wir es ändern vertrete
er die meinung dass denken ein prozess
oder eine fähigkeit ist die wir völlig
ohne körperliche organ einsetzen also
für ihn ist denken mit atomen oder mit
jeglichen corp körper das ist unmöglich
jeder der daher kommt und sagt ich bin
körperlich alles dies er ist für mich
wie ein vielleicht ein sehr feiner
körper in einem gruppenkurs körper kann
nicht erklären wie denken funktioniert
und viele touristen also viele die immer
noch heutzutage do liste
die touristische ansichten haben sind
auch dieser meinung also sie können
nicht vorstellen wie man von fleisch das
von dem fleisch meines gehirns zu denken
oder bewusstsein kommt drittes problem
wir wir brauchen nichts ein körper in
einem anderen körper
was wir brauchen ist irgendwas was
erklären kann kann wieso der ganze
körper diese lebensfunktionen besetzt
weil sie nicht als ob man sie sich vor
wir hätten ein mikroskop und dann würden
wir meinen finger anschauen und sehen
mag die nato müssen es gibt diese zellen
atomen und und platz und dann gibt es
diese hässliche atomen zu durchnässt
aber obwohl sie alle durchmisst sind
sind sie nicht wirklich durchmischt die
wein und wasser
wo auch immer weil es da ist auch wasser
dies sind nicht am gleichen ort das ist
das problem
aber was wir brauchen ist eine erklärung
wie jedes teilchen des körpers belebt
ist oder beseelt ist und das liefert
diese theorie nichts wir brauchen das
heißt wir brauchen eine theorie wonach
seele und körper haben gleichenorts sind
die müssen zusammen sein und jede
theorie wo die zelle ein weiterer körper
ist wird das nicht abliefern mindestens
nicht wenn sie das zweite körper nicht
durch und
mit dem groben körper durchmischt ist
interessanterweise kommen dann weitere
fürs offen eine generation später die
historiker die genau ein solch eine
solche theorie haben also für sie sind
keine atom westen die sind die alles
orte ließ gegner von atheismus und sagen
dass die seele wie ein heißer leyen ein
heißer luft ist was mit den körper durch
drinks oder durch den körper drängt also
überall wo mein körper hat hat man seele
die sind durch und durch gemischt die
wasser und wein
übrigens nie weiß das war so in wein
nicht mehr krieg durch durch und durch
gemessen weil atheismus war ist aber sie
wissen was ich meine
also durch eine durchmischung das ist
genau was die historiker dann vertreten
haben als eine theorie der seele
das ist nicht alles okay ist für die das
für die nächste 2000 jahre anna
touristische oder physikalische theorien
der zeile dann eliminiert hat für dieses
argument aber man kann schon sagen dass
die dass seine argumente sehr prägend
war dann für die geschichte der fluss
wie nach ihm weil viele für das offen
vor allem update der spätantike sind
schon der meinung dass die zellen nicht
körperlich sein kann
ok dann eine andere idee die er in
seinen vorgängern findet ist dass die
seele vielleicht doch kein körper ist
sondern ein nicht körper in bewegung ist
und zwar in selbst bewegung
denn das problem ist ist wahrnehmung und
bewegung zu erklären
also konzentrieren wir uns auf bewegung
wenn wir meinen schwarm anschauen sind
mein schwang seine uni schwamm
aber ich sage für die nächste 50 minuten
gehört dieser schwamm ihr okay wenn ich
an mein schwarm an und jetzt warten wir
bis der spass macht
[Musik]
ich dachte es bleibt die freunde des
schweizers die kommen bisher das war
nichts gemacht weiß nicht ob sie das von
hinten sehen können
falls sie das nicht senken hat er schon
bisher gar nichts gemacht
ich denke dass das nicht geht und das
sollte uns zu denken hören wieso kann
der schwamm wieso es dieser schwamm so
nutzlos
wieso macht ja nichts vermutung mein
schwarm hat keine seele und kann sich
deswegen nicht bewegen aber dass der
schwamm kann deutsches hier sehr gut
übrigens besser als ein großes englisch
das waren kann sich nicht bewegen
ich kann den schwamm aber mit bewegen
ja wenn sie das nochmal sehen
also schwamm kann in bewegung gebracht
werden kann sich aber nicht bewegen und
das ist genau der unterschied zwischen
leben lebewesen und nicht lebewesen
sogar pflanzen können sich bewegen
ja wir könnten sagen dass sie in der
lage sind ihre eigene potenziale täten
so verwirklichen oder zu aktualisieren
das heißt dass sie diese veränderung in
sich selbst vorbringen können zb dadurch
dass die nehrung verwenden um zu warten
oder fortpflanzung oder rötliche
bewegung wahrnehmung das alles können
wir wir lebewesen aus uns heraus machen
mit unseren eigenen ressourcen wenn ein
schwarm das nicht mal an
und genau das wollte platon erklären
leider ist der dialog wo er das sagt
nichts ein dialog den wir besprochen
haben
das heißt aber wir haben den pfeilern
gesprochen und die meisten leute würden
weiter und weiter und weiter ist sowieso
verwechseln sie können sie also im park
bei partys und so können sie
wahrscheinlich so tun als ob sie den
weitern weiters auch kennen weil niemand
in unterschied weiß okay
in dem fall das was übrigens ganz ganz
guter dialog ist haben wir eine passage
wohnbezirke thies argumentiert dass die
seele bewegung in den in den körper
verursachen kann weil die seele an sich
bewegend ist die serie ist selbst
bewegend und der körper ist mit ihm wird
mit ihm bewegt sozusagen alles ein
bisschen wie ich und mein schwarm der
der schwamm kann sich bewegen nur weil
ich mich warm in bewegung bringen und
ähnlicher weise ist mein körper
eigentlich wie ein schwamm
das würde ich nicht das würde es was sie
beim dayton sind und sie das alles
erklären worden sondern sie vielleicht
demgegenüber nicht sagen mein körper ist
wie ein schwarm kleid anderes beispiel
nehmen sie reisen oder sowas
aber unter uns ist mein körper wie ein
schwarm und am bau nach abendessen und
das heißt dass mein körper eigentlich
tot ist an sich dass das verbindet das
kann man ziemlich gut mit dem was wir in
weiden gesehen haben dass der tod also
wenn wenn wir sterben dass es die
trennung von seele und körper ja warum
weil der körper an sich nicht lebend ist
der körper braucht die seele um leben zu
sein um wahrnehmen und bewegen zu können
also wirken sagen es gibt sozusagen eine
kette also ich nehme das bewege den
schwamm dass wir würde von meinem körper
bewegt habe meinen körper würde von
meiner seele bewegt und damit diese
kette ein ende hat sagt platon ja das
besondere bei der seele ist dass die
zelle selbst bewegen ist
sie kann sich selbst bewegen wenn es
kein körper das machen kann
das ist eigentlich sehr schlau aber es
sagt aber nein funktioniert nichts
erstens ist verdienst als bewegung im
allgemeinen problematisch das sagt er
anderswo
aber was er hier sagt ist das kraton das
subjekt der bewegung falsch
identifiziert hat denn es ist nicht die
seele des tieres oder sogar der pflanze
der sicht bewegt was sich die sich
bewegt was sich bewegt ist das tier oder
das im allgemeinen das lebewesen die
rolle der seele ist nichts so soll ein
weiteres tier innerhalb des tieres zu
sein der sich bewegt und dann alles
andere in bewegung bringt was was ein
bisschen so es wie diese atome ssten
diese atome theorie weil für die atom
aston war das so wir haben
in den körper sie sind in bewegung und
das bringt die anti-atom-bewegung so
hier haben wir eine eine material ist in
bewegung was den körper dann in bewegung
bringt aber hat es wie gesagt es ist
alles grundsätzlich falsch diese annahme
oder dieser ansatz ist falsch was ihr
verstehen muss ist dass die seele nicht
das ist was irgendwas macht was das der
subjekt des handelns warst wachsens
wahrnehmen was auch immer das objekt ist
immer das lebewesen und die serie ist
das was all diese fähigkeiten oder
aktivitäten erklärt also würde eher
sagen wenn es das ist ein zitat aus mehr
oder weniger aus dem ersten buches aus
dem ersten buch das sagt alles
wenn ich würden werde werde ich wütend
durch meine seele
es ist nicht meine seele die wirkend
wird oder wenn ich und vielleicht weiß
bei solche beispiele solchen beispiel
könnten vielleicht denken
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen würde würde
ich sagen dass meine seele wütend wird
nicht ganz so klar
aber fangen wir mal was offensichtlich
ist daran werden wir sehen wenn ich das
mache würden wir es sagen dass meine
seele geht natürlich nichts ich gehe
und übrigens ist auch nicht mein körper
da geht was geht das bin ich und alles
was ich mache mache ich
und ich bin seele und körper und dass es
so sagen hatte solches durchbruch das
ist die grundlegende einsicht hatte die
die es ihm ermöglicht für alle eine
verbesserung zu geben gegenüber alle
andere zellen theorien was er sagt ist
das tier ist eine zusammensetzung als
seele und körper und das was alles macht
ist dass lebewesen und nicht die seele
auch nicht der körper das heißt nicht
unbedingt also dass es gibt zwei sachen
was das nicht heißt erstens gibt es
eigenschaften eines lebewesens die
wirklich nur zum körper zu schreiben
sind zum beispiel gewicht also ich habe
das ein das gewicht was ich habe was ich
nichts verraten werde alles etwas zwei
kilo mehr als nötig
gleich drei also nötig vielleicht für
wen war also mein körper hat ein gewicht
und nicht weil mein körper beseelt ist
beweis sie können mich umbringen nicht
machen
sie können mich umbringen ich würde
umfallen
also je nachdem wie sie mich umbringen
also wenn sie krank rate werfen werde
ich nicht nur umfallen sondern das heißt
zweite aber nehmen waren sie bringen
mich um in einer art und weise wo ich
umfalle und tod
ich habe immer noch mein gewicht und das
zeigt dass mein gewicht keine
eigenschaft dass die durch meine seele
zu erklären dass durch meine seele zu
erklären ist ist im allgemeinen
wahrnehmung und bewegung
ok also erstens gibt es schon
eigenschaften des tieres des lebewesens
was zum körper zu schreiben sind
zweitens kann es vorkommen vielleicht
dass wir manche fähigkeiten haben die
ohne den körper ausgeübt werden können
bisher war das noch nicht klar und das
wird erst im dritten buch das von über
die seele klar aber in die im dritten
buch erfahren wir das denken die vorher
gesagt keinen menschlichen organen
braucht selbst da aber würde alles dort
liest und das ist meiner meinung nach
nichts sagen die seele denkt sondern ich
denke mit meiner oder durch meine seele
die serie ist das was mir denken
ermöglicht nicht das was denkt genau wie
booten werden oder gehen oder seen oder
was auch immer
was er sagt hier was interessant ist
übrigens nämlich das dass wir oft bei
nebel lebensfunktionen lebensfunktionen
zwei aspekte sehen zum beispiel wenn ich
bitten werde
gibt es
er sagt mein verlangen nach rache
dass wir in wut und dann gibt es eine
körperliche erscheinung nämlich das
kochen des blutes um dem herz das was in
den körper körper vorkommt wenn ich mich
wenn ich mich berge aber wut besteht aus
beiden wut ist seele und körper zusammen
was machen und zusammen heißt es dass
ich das mache
also ich habe sehnsucht nach rache
die als kochen des blutes und dem herz
erscheint oder in dem kochen des blutes
passiert ist oder so und dann hier
können sie sehen vielleicht oder
vielleicht sogar ahnen dass manche
jetzige philosophen senkt zurückblicken
auf alles wissen sagen das ist gut
es ist der erste für das so also ich
glaube viele würden sagen viele für das
amt des geistes würden sagen das ist der
erste die erste philosophische erklärung
des lebens oder der sänger ist das erste
mal jemand was vernünftiger sagt oder
mindestens das was wir ernst nehmen
würden
weil das ist keine abgetrennte seele
dass keine lustige theorie mit feuer
oder atomen oder was auch immer
die hier sagt das warten ist das
kognitive fähigkeiten immer diese eine
diesen einen aspekt haben das würden
manche für das offene heutzutage
contents nennen vielleicht oder inhalt
zum beispiel sehnsucht nach rache haben
aber auch eine physikalische erscheinen
oder manifestation und wir können diese
beiden aspekte getrennt beobachten oder
betrachten aber sie sind nur ein denken
also man könnte sie sich vorstellen auch
bei den neuesten stand des gegen der
gehirnforschung könnte man sagen wut ist
ein zustand in dem gehirn aber trotzdem
immer noch sehnsucht nach rache ja es
ist nicht falsch
gut so ist der finne werde falsch wut
nur als ein zustand in dem gehirn zu
beschreiben weil man irgendwann würde
irgendwas wählen da würde man was nicht
verstehen oder übermut nämlich dass man
drache haben will
aber wenn man beide zusammen hält das
ist gut und machen vieles offen sagen
deswegen das alles hier sehr gut gemacht
hat also immer noch zu sagen
grob gesagt das ist noch gängig als
theorie der seele
allerdings eine kleine warnung dazu wenn
philosophen in diesem bereich solche
überlegungen führen was sie
normalerweise betrachten ist also die
die sagen philosophie des geistes class
wir meint und sie überlegen was passiert
wenn nicht würden werde wenn ich
meinungen dann habe wenn ich erfahrungen
habe und so weiter und so fort ist alles
sehr positiv
aber wie ich vorher gesagt habe ist
bewegung auch relevant also was wie
örtliche bewegung eines fuchses ist
genauso relevant für des visuellen
theorie wie denken oder bewusst sein und
man findet sie wie gesagt sogar bei
pflanzen also die theorie die alles hier
anbietet ist nicht nur eine philosophie
des geistes
das ist eine philosophie des lebens wo
ein eine philosophie des geistes als
fußnote rennen steigt oder oder als teil
davon
dann steigt das spiel allgemeiner und
breiter was er machen weil es nicht nur
philosophie des geistes aber ist
relevant für die jetzige verlust wie das
geist ist okay fragen zu dieser ersten
gute frage also um also bisher haben wir
nichts eigentlich herausgefunden was die
seele erst das kommt als nächstes wie
sehen werden ist seele ist für ihn nur
alle lebens fähigkeiten also wenn die
fähigkeiten wenn der körper nicht so
nicht mehr so ist dass der körper diese
fähigkeiten durchführen kann
ist der körper tot also das ist sehr
sehr funktional esstisch definiert also
je nachdem was man machen kann ist mein
leben oder tod
und wenn man ihn fragt okay aber wieso
ist er tot sagt er
schwerdt also dass die frage ist nur was
kannst du machen
und wenn du in der lage bist die
lebensfunktionen auszufüllen dann bist
du am leben und dann nicht so bist du
tot
und dann bleiben nur eben diese
eigenschaften wie gewicht oder so
bewegungen habe ich bester boxer des
kanisters und das eis täters heißt es er
würde das wort ästhetik haben zum
beispiel das ist das war das erste buch
von über diese zweite buch fängt damit
an dass er sagt dass er versucht serie
zu definieren und hier nimmt er als
raster seien seine theorie an die wir
schon in der physik gesehen haben mit
den vier ursachen und so und er sagt
offensichtlich also wenn wir das
anschauen
offensichtlich müssen wir denken dass
diese entweder form oder materie ist
weil wir ein bisschen zurück zu ihrer
frage betont aber am anderen ende denken
wir an geburt was passiert wenn ein
lebewesen dann entsteht die entstehung
ist eine veränderung wo irgend was
zuerst am leben ist und dann
entschuldigung nicht am leben ist und
dann am leben ist und dann ist tot
natürlich genau die gegenteilige
veränderung also wir brauchen irgendwas
was durch diese veränderungen dann
konstant bleibt erhalten bleibt und was
das kommt offensichtlich ist die seele
mit der form zu assoziieren und nicht
mit der materie materie wäre sowas wie
blut oder fleisch oder sowas und das
wird als lebewesen organisiert und diese
organisation ist die form und das ist
die seele also sein erstes ein erster
versuch
sie definieren ist sie relativ leicht
das ist halt die form der ist lebewesens
und das ist sozusagen fällt einfach als
einfache antwort aus seiner
physikalischen theorie oder ist eine
nation der natur flüsse wie aus
allerdings ist ein bisschen kompliziert
als dass weil diese wörter dynamisch und
energie nicht so einfach sind wie man
meinen könnte weil bisher habe ich immer
gesagt es gibt zwei möglichkeiten es
gibt der name ist und energiepotenzial i
tät wirklichkeit zb ich bewege mich
nichts das auf die lippen mit welchem
ich nicht war aber in prozentzahlen
bewegung und dann bin ich der
wirklichkeit nach in bewegung ja gut
aber wenn man überlegt und als dort ist
es natürlich meistern überlegen
also er hat überlegt wenn man überlegt
sieht man dass es mehrere stufen von
potentially tät und wirklichkeit nämlich
und das und das nennt er erste demenz
oder erste potenzial i tät zweite
potenzial i tät erste wirklichkeit
zweite wirklichkeit und erste
wirklichkeit und zweite potenzial ead
sind identisch das ist die idee also wir
haben
[Musik]
so also dass das klar ist okay
vielleicht leiter wenn ich ihnen ein
beispiel geben zurückzog swahili nehmen
wir jemanden der kein israeli kann
nämlich nehmen wir mich kann keiner hier
trotzdem würde ich behaupten dass ich in
der lage wäre ist weiter lesen lernen
vielleicht nicht fließend aber wie
könnte also wenn wenn jemand mich zur
ostküste von afrika schicken würde und
sagen
ab jetzt musst du dich auf zwei elite
schlagen
ich würde ihn nach von zehn jahre
einigermaßen zu erhellen können
ja und das gilt für uns alle aber sie
können schon sehr viel aber sie haben
bleibt haben schon bemerkt dass er
bisher das dass er das bisher nicht
bewiesen hat
aber wir nehmen an dass sie sie sitze
ich an als ob sie sehr ehrlich sind also
wir nehmen an dass das stimmt er kann
zwar nie aber tut es nicht also man
könnte sagen ich kann so will er auch
also ich habe die gunners die prozent
sanität zwar hin zu sprechen er auch
aber offensichtlich in ganz anderen
weisen weil er könnte dass jede sekunde
machen und ich nichts und wer alles dort
liest heißt das dass wir zwei stufen von
prozent steht definieren müssen wir
haben die erste stufe wo man eine
fähigkeit erwerben könnte oder man
könnte sagen ein bisschen verwirrend
aber das ist dass es die fähigkeit eine
fähigkeit zu erwerben
ja also ich habe die fähigkeit die
fähigkeit zu erwerben zwei helis
sprachen und dann gibt es die stufe wo
man diese fähigkeit schon erworben hat
ihr zustand der sprache gegenüber weil
sie haben rücken und da ist auch
offensichtlich dass sie habe nicht
sprechen können als sie geboren sind
oder das haben sie dann danach gelernt
vielleicht als kind selbst ich weiß dass
es schwer zu glauben ist aber als ich
geboren wurde konnte ich nicht kommt
konnte ich noch nicht deutsch
das habe ich sehr mühsam dann erwerben
müssen meine deutschkenntnisse
wir haben etwas zu spät angefangen und
das heißt dass ich nie so muttersprache
klingen kann sie aber schon aber aber in
dieser hinsicht sind wir gleich also
würden wir alle haben deutsch kenntnisse
erworben nachdem jemand der kein deutsch
kann aber ich kann nicht fragen weil die
würden mich nicht verstehen
ich gehe davon aus alle können hier
deutsch stärken
vielleicht ist jetzt jemand davon ja
endlich anfangen englisch zu sprechen
solange also wir können alle deutschland
konnten das noch als neugeborene babys
natürlich nicht neugeborene babys sind
sich alle sprachen in der stufe der
ersten prozent sanität wenn man die
strafe r wird ist man in der zweiten
potenzielle der erste wirklichkeit erste
wirklichkeit ist aktiv eine fähigkeit zu
besitzen die man vielleicht erworben hat
aber vielleicht nicht wie sie gleich
wenn zweite wirklichkeit ist wenn man
die fähigkeit einsatz zum beispiel ich
setze meine deutschkenntnisse an also
ich verwende meine fähigkeit deutsch zu
sprechen
sie verwenden alle gerade ihre fähigkeit
deutschen verstehen was man leise machen
kann aber trotzdem machen sie was jetzt
aktives sie verstehen gerade deutsch ja
wenn er anfangen würde zwar hin zu
sprechen könnten wir das nicht mal wir
würden nicht verstehen was er sagt ja
und vielleicht würde man deswegen denken
okay wenn man neu geboren ist hat man
gar keine fähigkeiten da kann man keine
tollen spielen ersparen
alles mann ist lehrer so sagen aber das
stimmt natürlich nichts weil neugeborene
babys viele sachen machen können
sie können neben verarbeiten sie können
ein bisschen sehen sie können hören
sie können sogar hören als sie noch im
bauch sind und so weiter und so fort
zwischen atmen hat herzschlag und so
weiter und so fort
und das zeigt uns dass nur leben mit
sich viele aktive fähigkeiten bringt und
das zeigt dass seele nichts eine erste
potenzielle täter ist sondern eine
zweite potenzielle täter erste
wirklichkeit seele ist
oder bringt sich bringt mit sich
wirkliche fähigkeiten nicht unbedingt
erworbene fähigkeiten weil man sie aus
natur und sozusagen kostenlos haben kann
sobald man existiert hat man diese
fähigkeiten und das sind genau die
fähigkeiten die alle lebewesen haben ist
übrigens ein
es gibt also gegenbeispiele die ein
bisschen verwirrend sind zum beispiel
gibt es tiere die grenzen wenn sie
geboren sind und dann danach sehen
können also ein bisschen das eine
ausnahme weil da solche tiere fangen
hier an und erwerben dann wahrnehmung
nach 22 monaten oder jahren lange das
dauert das sie sehen können
aber grundsätzlich können alle lebewesen
ihre typische funktionen von wahrnehmung
und bewegung
entweder sofort einsetzen sobald sie
existieren wurde nach einem natürlichen
prozess der entwicklung erwerben ok und
die und was wirklich sehr interessant
ist wenn man zurückdenkt so zum beispiel
plattform oder die automessen die sagten
er ist irgendwie an sich selbst in
bewegung
man sieht wie andere sorten ist das
versteht er würde sagen nein
die serie ist das wodurch man sich
bewegt weil die seele
eine fähigkeit erst hier ist eine aktive
fähigkeit oder bzw alle aktive
fähigkeiten die zu den relevanten dazu
der relevanten art von lebewesen gehören
zb können vögel der natur nach fliegen
wir nicht aber das ist nur weil sie eine
andere art lebewesen sind pflanzen
können nichts wahrnehmen
sie würden nicht serien mindestens und
sie können nicht denken
sie können aber all die relevante
fähigkeiten ausführen zb richtung der
sonne drehen nahrung einnehmen und
verarbeiten und so weiter und das heißt
gerade sword wii ist dass die seele an
sich nichts tut wie wir gesehen haben zb
die seele bewegt sich nicht die seele
ist das wodurch man sich bewegt und
jetzt sieht man warum
der grund dafür ist dass die seelen nur
das ist die das ist das was die
fähigkeiten des lebewesens bereitstellt
wo es vielleicht sogar mit den ganzen
der ganzen hand sammlung von fähigkeiten
identisch und das für mich ein bisschen
zurück zu ihrer frage was ist wenn man
stirbt wenn man stirbt verliert man die
fähigkeiten da ist die seele weg ok
jetzt haben sie vielleicht sofort schon
gesehen dass alles okay ist anscheinend
eine etwas kontroverse these vertreten
hat nämlich dass die seele nicht
überleben kann wenn der körper stirn
weil die seele anscheinend nur aus
diesen fähigkeiten besteht
und sobald der körper keine fähigkeiten
er hat ist man tot um die seele ist
anscheinend weg das scheint die
integration zu sein
aber vorsicht wieso er gesagt habe ist
es nicht der körper der wütend wird oder
der geht es ist das label wesen oder der
mensch in unserem fall und das heißt das
so lang wir fähigkeiten haben die wofür
man den körper nicht braucht ist das
theoretisch möglich dass diese
fähigkeiten weiterhin ausgeübt werden
können oder eingesetzt werden können
nachdem der körper stimmt also wenn wir
irgend eine fähigkeit haben die nicht
körperlich erscheint oder nicht
körperlich eingesetzt wird könnte man
sich vorstellen vielleicht dass der
körper stirbt und dass der mensch
weiterhin mit mindestens der in der
hinsicht dass
irgendeine fähigkeit bleibt was schon
anwesen war bleibt erhalten weil diese
fähigkeit den körper nichts verbraucht
klingt aber es ziemlich unwahrscheinlich
bis man bemerkt dass alte schotte ließ
lieber nächste woche ist in wen und wie
schon erwähnt habe im dritten buch sagte
ausdrücklich das denken kein organ
keinen körperlichen organen braucht und
von daher haben war es die typische
auslegung in der spätantike und
mittelalter sogar die einstimmige
auslegung von art wie es war
ja natürlich was soll ich sagen will ist
dass diese nach dem tod leben kann aber
nur als geist nur als denkendes prinzip
nachdem wir sterben sind wir sozusagen
reine philosophen und nächste woche
werden wir diskutieren müssen ob das
plausibel ist oder nicht
die interessanterweise obwohl das damals
also dieses sehr gute als wirkliche
scanner von damals waren wie gesagt
wirklich einstimmig dass es ein leben
nach dem tod klappte ist es jetzt mehr
oder weniger einstimmig und hat es dort
ließ forscher dass er das nicht klappt
es kommt darauf an ob wenn man thomas
von aquin fragt sagt er natürlich wenn
man christoph vermutet dass er sagen wir
nein natürlich nicht
natürlich würde ich sagen dass die zelle
mit dem körper stirbt an bruder
vielleicht würde er so in das ist was
ich sagen würde um keine wörter in
meinem geschätzten kollegen in seinem
mund legen was ich sagen würde ist
sterben ist noch mal was was das label
wesen macht nicht das nicht ein
also sterben ist nichts das ein ding was
der körper oder die seele macht genau
wie wütend werden stirbt das lebewesen
und ins das lebewesen ist das ganze
denken das ist sozusagen also plattform
hat direkt dass die trennung der seele
und dem körper aber die seele ist nur
die fähigkeiten des lebewesens also wenn
die fähigkeiten nicht mehr anwesend sind
ist das label dessen tod und das war es
das ist meine vermutung aber man muss
schon sagen dass es sehr sehr zögerlich
ist wenn es um diese frage geht also
wenn man bedenkt fahrten hat diesen
ganzen dialog den weiter und geschrieben
um diese frage zu beantworten ob die
zellen nach dem tod leben überleben kann
oder ist ist sehr auffällig dass es nie
diese frage ausdrücklich beantwortet es
gibt eine stelle wo er sagt wir müssen
uns fragen ob der kessel in dem körper
ist wie der matrose in einem schiff aber
das beantworten wir später was er nie
tut und was er was er wahrscheinlich
meint ist der schiff segelt mit demut
mit den matrosen kommt in den hafen und
der matrose kann dann weitergehen ohne
den chef also die seele werde dann wie
der matrose der und tod werde wie in den
hafen ankommen und dann würde die seele
einfach weiter tun das was sie tut
aber ich denke dass es sehr
unwahrscheinlich jetzt wollte ich für
die letzte viertelstunde wahrnehmung
beschränken aber hat jemand fragen das
war das wichtigste wollte er hat jemand
fragen dazu
ja
ja oder die gleiche art zähle also nicht
die identische seele natürlich also sie
haben eine serie ich eine zweite
ok also sie wollen wissen ob zählen
individuell existieren ja
leider ist das eine sehr gute frage
in der mitte physik gibt es eine sehr
lange besprechung über diese beziehung
form und materie im rahmen von der im
rahmen der frage was das eigentliche
substanz ist oder wesen also dass das
griechische wort das museum und das
kommt einfach von den berg hinein seien
also das als könnte man sagt dass seine
übersetzen oder und normal sagen wir
substanz und seine frage ist was ist da
eigentlich substanz hier form oder
materie nicht oder die zusammensetzung
aus dem 2 also dass lebewesen hier und
dann geht er hin und her super
kompliziert und steht am ende sagen dass
der wagen nicht so wie sonst die form
ist nicht die die zusammensetzung und
wenn das stimmt dachten okay also die
das individuum innerhalb des substances
ist eigentlich die form
allerdings sagt er auch zum beispiel
alle menschen sind der form nach
identisch aber ein aber der zahl nach
nicht identisch und von daher denken
viele
wir haben wissen alle einfach mensch
werden aber durch die materie individuen
also kurzum ist die frage woher in die
vita individualität bei bisher kommt
sehr sehr schwierig und es ist vor allem
nicht klar ob formen als sich universell
sind oder einzelnen sachen
aber eine mögliche auslegung mindestens
werde dass jede form ist auch die form
des tisches es gibt hier eine form das
ist ein einzel denn in einem einzel
deckname in dem tisch und ähnlicher
weise ist meine seele ein dsl ist ein
zweites ding und dann unsere körper auch
und die kommen zusammen um einen
menschen einen zweiten menschen
produzieren
aber es ist wirklich unklar es ist
schwierige frage
wenn ich das sagen haben ist die
fallhöhe atome maschinen
ok also hat erkennt dass manche sachen
harte fakten sind die welt sie sind die
produkte der kunst technik und daher das
wort technologie und natürlich hat er
keine keine erfahrung mit so was die
roboter obwohl man schon mechanische
puppen in der antike hatten die ab und
zu in philosophischen texten vorkommen
als vergleich aber aristoteles würde
sagen dass ein artefakt immer sein
prinzip der bewegung von außen erworben
hat und jetzt nicht sozusagen innerlich
oder n geboren und er würde sehr stark
zwischen harte fakten und natur
substanzen unterscheiden was er dann
sagen würde wenn ich wenn er zum
beispiel wenn er weit männer anschauen
würde
hier haben ein artefakt der erinnerung
sie haben alle plate war nie gesehen
oder wenn nicht irgendein film netz sehr
fortgeschrittenen roboter okay hier
haben wir roboter die meinungen haben
die sprechen können und so weiter und so
fort vielleicht würde es an
schwierig für meine theorie
wahrscheinlich weil er es so stark
zwischen natur sachen und technisch
unterscheidet aber er könnte für light
zu geben wenn ein wenn ein artefakt so
weit entwickelt ist dass das ein inneres
prinzip der bewegung hat könnte das
irgendwie ein künstliches lebewesen sein
oder so was
wer fast eine mischung aus seinen zwei
kategorien ok wahrnehmung und das wollte
ich hauptsächlich erwähnen weil es ein
sehr gutes beispiel dass von dem was wir
schon gesehen haben
ok nehmen wir an dass ich was sie jemand
was vorschlagen was ich sehen könnte
was da okay
[Musik]
in zu kleinen bars malen
weil sich ein mädel wesen brauche in dem
beispiel okay hier ist mein auge ok so
was passiert wenn ich den baum
wahrnehmen
jetzt konzentrieren wir uns auf die
farbe des baumes der baum jetzt sagen
wir es ist noch frühling oder sommer
noch nicht herbst also die farbe ist
grün und zufällig ist ist das wirklich
grün
das ist praktisch was muss passieren
damit ich ein baum war nehme etwas
kompliziert alles was ich würde sagen
dass im allgemeinen wahrnehmung nur
durch kontakt stattfinden kann also für
ihn ist tasten irgendwie dass die dir
das grundlegende beispiel von
wahrnehmung und er hat gemerkt dass
schmecken und oder mindestens schmecken
und tasten durch kontakt funktionieren
und deswegen ist für ihn etwas
rätselhaft wie diese andere sind es
modalitäten funktionieren griechen sehen
hören aber seine erklärung ist
irgendetwas passiert in der luft
zwischen wahrnehmenden und objekt was
die wahrnehmung ermöglicht bei ist hat
er natürlich recht
das sind die wellen oder vibrationen in
der luft
er sagt was ähnliches bei riechen sind
das die partikeln die durch die luft
kommen
er spricht nicht von partikeln er
spricht einfach von dem geruch
das könnte den baum vielleicht auch
riechen wenn es die richtige art baumes
das war ein geruch durch die luft zu
meiner nase kommt weniger weise wenn die
luft zwischen mir und dem bahn bereit
ist die form der farbe
weiterzuvermitteln und das heißt für ihn
nicht nur dass nichts im weg steht wie
ein mauer sondern auch das licht hier
anwesend sein muss
also man kann nur durch beleuchtete luft
sehen
laut sonys dann ist diese luft ist ein
medium zwischen mir und dem baum und
ermöglicht dass ich in basel
das ist wie eine art kontakt also das
was als ob ich durch die luft den baum
mit meinen augen berühren kann
okay aber dass das nicht das
interessante für uns für uns ist das
interessante dass er dieses prozesses
genau nach diesem muster analysiert
alles was wir haben in dem auge ist eine
erste wirklichkeit wurde zweite konzert
potenzial i tät nämlich
nämlich sehvermögen oder sagen wir
einfach sicht
sicht- oder sehvermögen ist genau so was
wie wir schon beschrieben haben als wir
allgemein über die seele gesprochen
haben
das heißt es ist eine aktive aktuelle
wirkliche fähigkeit irgendwas zu tun
nämlich zu sehen
was wäre dann erste potenzial itt
potenzial i tät würde irgendwas gehören
was ein auge werden könnte zum beispiel
blut war oder fleisch oder was auch
immer
was vielleicht in den in dem bauch der
mutter ist aber noch nicht als auch
apfel konstruiert oder organisiert ist
okay nachdem man die form des lebewesens
hat hat dieses stück fleisch ist es
dieses wird gleich ein vermögen nämlich
sehvermögen das ist sogar gut weil das
wort liest dass wir dass wir das
sehvermögen benennen
also wir deuten darauf dass das eine
fähigkeit ist aber als nur sehvermögen
zu haben heißt natürlich nicht dass man
sieht das können sie jetzt tassen wenn
sie wollen wenn sie alle die augen
schließen das wäre lustig finden sie
alle die arme schließen alle
ok jetzt auch machen ok als sie die
haben zu hatten konnten sie nicht sehen
jetzt wieder schon aber sie waren mit
blind sie hatten oder wenn sie schlafen
das heißt nicht dass sie blind sind sie
haben noch die fähigkeit sie setzten die
fähigkeiten nicht nur nur nicht ein
also hier haben wir vielleicht nur
fleisch hier haben wir nicht nur sicht
oder sehvermögen sondern sehen dass es
zweite wirklichkeit das wo man wirklich
sieht und wenn er dann sagt was was das
erst aktiv zu sehen sagt er
ja das ist leicht zu erklären hier haben
wir was was der wirklichkeit nach grüner
ist ja was wirklich grün aktives aktive
wirkliche farbe hier haben wir eine
potenzial ead zu sehen was ist das ist
eine prozentual i tät diese farbe zu
erwerben
die farbe wird durch die luft vermittelt
beleuchtete luft durch die luft
vermittelt wird hier aktualisiert und
das heißt nur dass die fähigkeit grün zu
sehen aktiviert ist oder wird
also das heißt dass die sicht das
sehvermögen eine potenziell alle farben
oder hat schon die farben der prozent
sie täten nach genau wie wir alle
alle sprachen können aber nur die
prozent nach oder besser gesagt sie
können deutsch sprechen aber nur die
potenz die der potenzial i tät nach weil
sie haben eine aktive potenzial i tät
deutsch zu sprechen aber nichts war hier
mit ausnahmen
ok also genau wie zum beispiel jetzt
können sie alle flecken sie alle nichts
sehen was lila ist also diejenige die
nehmen die händler jemand der milan hat
sie können alle jetzt im moment kein
lila sehen aber potenzielle schon
sie haben all die fähigkeit lena zu
sehen ich musste nur was lieder aus der
tasche nehmen das wäre gut wenn ich das
vorbereitet hätte habe ich aber nicht
nächste nächstes jahr vielleicht heute
nicht nehmen ein tuch aus der tasche des
lila signal ist sofort wieder sehen
genau wie sie jetzt alle sofort deutsch
sprechen könnten wenn sie so unhöflich
werden während der vorlesung zu sprechen
also kurzum hier potenzielle farbe hier
aktive farbe oder wirkliche farbe farbe
der wirklichkeit nacht und in der
richtigen situation wenn die
voraussetzungen anwesend sind wird die
potentially tät verwirklicht von der
anwesenden farben
ok also das ist eine typische
veränderung verfahre suisse die materie
der veränderung ist das auge dass es was
durch die veränderung erhalten bleibt
zuerst sieht die fahrt das auge oder
vielleicht die sicht keine grüne farbe
und dann schon also grünes abwesend und
dann anwesend typische veränderungen
auch andere richtung ist auch weg kann
grün nichts mehr sehen
dann gehe ich wieder von wirklichkeit zu
potenzial i tät man sieht wie allgemein
diese theorie ist und wie wirksam das
ist natürlich könnte man fragen ok aber
was heißt das wirklich das heißt das
dass das auge aktuell oder der
wirklichkeit nach grün wird und hier
gibt es eine streit in der
forschungsliteratur alles los sagt dass
wir bei wahrnehmung die form übernehmen
ohne die materie habe es nicht klar was
das heißt viele denken heißt es sich von
seinem form ohne materie über zu
übernehmen heißt so was wie die form
aber in einer anderen art und weise zu
besitzen als der baum sie besetzt war
der baum ist grün so dass man ihn als
grün sehen kann
aber man würde nicht denken dass mein
auge grün wird wenn ich die form des
grünes übernehme weil ich grün sehe ja
aber es gab es gibt forscher und hier
ist der der das wirklich vorgeschlagen
hat switches über die ein kollege von
mir oder eben ein kollege aus london
und er hat er hatte argumentiert man
habe mehrere passagen im zweiten buch
das von über die serie hat er
argumentiert nein alles so wie es denkt
jedes mal dass wir wahrnehmen passiert
irgendwas in dem körper was die form
nach abends was man draußen findet also
das heißt im fall des sehens wenn sie
diesen baum anschauen würde die
flüssigkeit in dem auge grün werden und
wenn sie mein auge ausschneiden können
nochmal bitte nicht machen aber wenn sie
das auch machen könnten ohne meine sich
zu zerstören was natürlich nicht gehen
würde
sie wurden sehen da es grünes wasser
drin praktisch alle haben gesagt das ist
doch blödsinn hat es sollte das kann
nicht so lächerlich seien aber aber
vielleicht leider gibt es schon
anzeichen dass er wirklich sehr oft
diese kognitive fähigkeiten mit
körperliche veränderung verbindet denken
wir noch mal an dieses beispiel mit wut
das war wie gesagt das war ein zitat was
ich gesagt habe vorher das aber nicht
erfunden das mit dem kochen im blut das
ist was er wirklich sagt also da
passiert was im körper und das hat diese
zwei aspekte die sozusagen
psychologischer ebene brache nach rache
zu suchen und kochen das blut das das
ist der körperliche aspekt ähnlicher
weise hier werde die erfahrung des
sehens werde die kognitive ebene und
dann ist die körperliche ebene nach
sotschi grün werden buchstäblich grund
werden
das ist eine ein streit innerhalb der
forschung und ein grund warum sollte das
mag sagen wollte ist dass er eben diese
idee hatte die vorher erwähnt habe viele
jetzige philosophen des geistes denken
alles hatte was brecht irgendwie
also diese psychologische ereignisse
haben körperlichen erscheinungen
das ist genau was zu hause behalten
wollte aber im fall von seen und er
dachte ist es wirklich interessant also
grün werden in der flüssigkeit des auges
das ist für sony ist nur das ist was
sicht ist und es ist wirklich das wäre
wirklich interessant war dann würde
alles natürlich sehr viele für das offen
des geistes sie würden sagen körperlich
war körperliche veränderungen die
richtig verstanden ist nur eine
kognitive veränderung also es war
musikalische philosophie des geistes
wenn das stimmt wir werden die
gelegenheit haben das tiefe zu
besprechen
nicht dass mit dem bau gearbeitet das
ganze problem nächste woche wenn wir
nächste woche geist bayer dass diese
beschwerden werden und vielleicht auch
ein bisschen gott oh gott
ok vielen dank und bis nächste woche